good morning John good morning it's a
reunion video surprise it's a pizza miss
miracle we didn't plan this our cousin
is just getting married it'd plan I'm
gonna take my shirt off so you can see
my Pete my burnt pizza John there's only
five days left in pizza miss you have to
get all of your pizza miss Kier right
now at dftba.com sorry what were you
saying I recently discovered that you
can search all of the vlogbrothers
comments yeah now we are going to find
out what we look like according to the
really nice people who leave comments on
vlogbrothers videos almost all of our
comments are lovely some of these are
not Hank looks like Minkus from Boy
Meets World I got I want to quite a bit
yeah I mean I see it okay but why does
Middle School John look like Minkus from
Boy Meets John you're looking
deliciously Jimmy Neutron today Jimmy
Neutron looks like the caricature artist
at Disneyland was drawing me you've been
getting Jimmy Neutron since like 2008 in
the video where you introduced Henry
yeah Sammy says hello I'm James Neutron
senior and this is lil Jimmy
Hank looks like handsome Squidward I
just realized that John looks like the
scammer guy who's always trying to say
look at my house in my Lamborghini in
this Lamborghini in that way oh yeah
totally looking guy has multiple Lambos
he's got it figured out holy SH merg
MSRP of a house head looks like a weeble
wobble
yeah they weevil and they wobble but
they don't fall down anyone think that
John kind of looks like middle aged
James Potter is that redundant isn't
James Potter always middle yeah I'm
Harry Potter books well I think he's
sort of late early aged and then he's
just 21 years old 21 years old in that
case I feel that James Potter was
miscast there was never a middle aged
James Potter that never happened until
me Hank on the guitar looks like one of
those Proclaimers from that scottish
twins duo i also have John really does
look like one of the Proclaimers they
seem like nice lads I also proclaim all
baton Hank looks like the male
protagonist of a young adult urban
fantasy novel John's nose looks like a
pristine piece of plastic is it me or
does Hank look like the guy from the
Welch's grape commercials and other Food
Network shows Alton Brown this is why
you never do a commercial because
forever after no matter what
you're the Welch's grape guy also
apparently that's one of the Food
Network shows yeah there are so many
commercials on linear television it is
essentially its own show John Green
looks like Megamind with hair I look way
more like Bernard from Megamind way I
look exactly like Bernard from Mecca ma
I mean I searched Bernard from Megamind
and like on the third line as a picture
of you next to Bernard for Megamind
normally I think Hank looks pretty old
but next to John he looks like a young
man is it but I think John looks like a
young Santa Claus you're not old you're
like a young Santa Claus John looks like
a tired man trying to look wide-awake
yeah me too pink looks like Scott
Pilgrim John's hair looks like the dust
from under my bed if you turn off the
volume on one of Hanks videos it looks
like he's conducting an orchestra
John Loki looks like Tom Hanks I'll take
it in that sunglasses sport coat t-shirt
combination Hank looks like every guy
who works at a start-up and who's tied
to his VP of something or other and
likes to talk about company culture to
real there was a whole separate category
of looks like and that's what John Green
looks like when he has a mustache let me
go through it for you great John Green
looks like the guy you glanced at at
Walmart John Green looks like an 80s
substitute teacher with that stache and
I don't hate it
John Green international best-selling
author and Ned Flanders double with that
mustache combo John cream looks like the
protagonist from the movie her the guy
you glanced at at Walmart might be the
greatest bird I've ever received in my
whole life all right we have to go to a
wedding now we have to go to a wedding
now get your pizza messed up at
dftba.com John I will continue to see
you now yeah that seems about right